- All right, my name is Rod Ferguson
and I'm the chair of Women's,
Gender, and Sexuality Studies.
It's my pleasure to welcome
you to our 2022 Brudner Event.
This is a very special moment for us
because this is the first
time that we've had it
since the lockdown.
The Brudner Prize established
in 2000, is awarded annually
to an accomplished scholar,
artist, or activist
whose work has made
significant contributions
to LGBT studies and LGBT communities.
All right, we have
decided to pluralize that
this evening with the panel.
And tonight's panelists
certainly fit that description.
Our event is named after James Brudner
who was an AIDS activist, urban planner,
journalist, and photographer.
A man of wit and compassion,
outsize knowledge and curiosity,
Brudner valued both academic
inquiry and direct action.
He spent 12 years as a policy analyst
for the city of New York.
He also earned an MA in journalism
from New York University,
and wrote for various publications
on gay and AIDS-related topics.
He became a member of ACT UP,
the Treatment Action Group,
and other organizations after
the death of his twin brother,
Eric of AIDS in 1987.
He worked on treatment
and prevention issues
with the National Institutes of Health,
pharmaceutical corporations,
and federal agencies.
In his final years, he
devoted much of his time
to traveling the back roads of
rural America with a camera.
La MaMa Galleria in New
York mounted an exhibition
of his photographs in 1997.
He died of AIDS-related
illness on September 18th, 1998
at the age of 37.
Through his will, he established
the Brudner Prize at Yale
as a quote, perpetual
annual prize, end quote,
for scholarship and activism
on gay and lesbian history
and contemporary experience.
Our thanks go first to
the Brudner Executors,
Steven Carlin, Michael
Cormier and Ben Pesner.
Also, we'd like to thank the WGSS staff,
Ellen Cupo, Moe Gardner,
Keith Geriak and Linda Relyea
for the support that they offered.
Our thanks also to Rick Leone
from Yale Broadcast Center
for AV support.
Our thanks also go to
the LGBT Studies committee
made up of Jill Richards,
the committee chair,
Joe Fischel, Scott
Herring and Greta LaFleur.
Particularly, we want to thank Joe
for organizing tonight's panel.
Joe, who is the author of "Screw Consent:
"A Better Politics of Sexual Justice"
and "Sex and Harm in the Age of Consent"
will introduce the panelists.
Please welcome Joe Fischel.
(audience applauding)
- I'll have you go first.
(Joe laughs)
- It's better that way.
- Yeah.
This is better, this is better.
Okay.
Hi, everyone and thank you, Rod.
Great, so yeah, thank you.
Welcome to the Brudner.
I'm gonna keep my comments short
and then I will introduce the speakers
and the introductions will also be short.
I apologize that I'm gonna
lift my introductions
right from the program
that you are holding,
which we lifted from their websites.
But the point of keeping it short
is that you can hear them and not me.
So the question I will
soon pose to our panelists
is anchored by two, or we
could think it of as anchored
by two geopolitical phenomena.
The first, Russia's war against Ukraine.
And even the most materialist
intersectional feminist
scholar wonders sometimes,
isn't all of that sex and
gender stuff superfluous
or epiphenomenal to the
brutality and violence of war?
Of course, many scholars and
some scholars in this room
have written about the
implication of war making,
war legitimation and insistent normativity
around sex and gender.
Many have pointed out how
Russian officials and pundits
have drawn on gayness,
gender non-normativity
as threats to Russia,
Russian civilization,
and children in particular,
to authorize Russian aggression
and its aggregation of power.
So the second anchor point,
maybe a surprise to nobody.
We could take anxiety generating stock
of the legislative attack
on girls and women,
queer kids and trans kids,
an attack ever more vicious and lethal
against girls, women, and queer
and trans kids minoritized
along other axes of inequality,
race, class, citizenship status.
If commentators note
the rhetorics of gender
and sexual normativity
that scaffold Russian authoritarianism,
we might observe how anti-gay, anti-trans,
and anti-women legislation rests
extraordinary regulatory
surveillance and punitive power
into the hands of our legislators.
So a thought behind the
question, what is sexual justice
is how to think those phenomena
and those dangers together,
even as the scale of our scholars' answers
will travel from the couple
form to the planetary.
So that's kind of all I've
got by way of scaffolding.
I'm gonna introduce our speakers
and kind of more formally
ask them this question.
So, if the font were bigger.
Okay, so Paisley Currah is a professor
of Political Science and
Women's & Gender Studies
at Brooklyn College and the
Graduate Center of CUNY.
Professor Currah has written
widely on transgender issues,
including on topics such as discrimination
and sex reclassification,
and the transgender rights movement.
He is the author and editor
of over 30 articles and books
and co-founder of the leading journal
in transgender studies, "TSQ:
"Transgender Studies Quarterly".
Currah's newest book, sex
is, there's a typo here,
"Sex Is as Sex Does: Governing
Transgender Identity"
will be released in the
spring of 2022 by NYU Press.
I should say that my lecture
in gender justice power institutions
have the extraordinary opportunity
to read some of Professor Currah's book
and also texts of our
other panelists today,
which has been fantastic.
Che Gossett is the racial
justice postdoctoral fellow
in initiative for a just society
at the Center for
Contemporary Critical Thought
at Columbia university.
Che Gossett is a black,
non-binary femme writer.
They'll be a visiting scholar
at the Center for Life-Writing
at Wolfson College,
Oxford University in 2022/23.
Gossett was a 2019/2020
Helena Rubinstein Fellow
in Critical Studies,
in the Whitney Independent Study Program
as well as a 2020/2021 graduate fellow
at the Center for Cultural
Analysis at Rutgers University.
They also co-edited with
professor David Getsy.
I love David Getsy.
They co-edited with Professor David Getsy
a syllabus on trans and non-binary methods
for Art Journal which
just recently received
the 2022 CAA Journal Award.
Tey Meadow, associate
professor of Sociology
at Columbia University.
Tenured like last week, so yay.
(audience applauding)
Professor Meadow is associate
professor of sociology
at Columbia.
Her research and writing
on gender, sexuality
and intimacy centers deep
ethnographic immersion,
and in-depth interviewing.
She's the author of "Trans Kids:
"Being Gendered in the
Twenty-First Century"
and co-editor of "Other Please Specify:
"Queer Methods in Sociology",
as well as numerous scholarly titles.
She is currently completing
a new ethnographic book,
tentatively titled "Edge Play:
"The Erotic Life of Social Difference".
Shatema Threadcraft,
associate professor of
Gender and Sexuality Studies,
Philosophy, and Political
Science at Vanderbilt University.
Professor Threadcraft is the
author of "Intimate Justice:
"The black Female Body
and the Body Politic."
which was the winner
of the National Women's
Studies Association
Sara H Whaley Award for the
Best Book on Women and Labor.
The 2017 W. E. B. Du Bois
Distinguished Book Award
from the National Conference
of black Political Scientists.
And finally, the 2017 Best Book Award
for the American Political
Science Association's Race,
Ethnicity, and Politics Organized Section.
It's an awesome book.
So those are my introductions.
And I will leave with the question,
what is sexual justice?
What does sexual justice
demand institutionally,
politically, ethically, and aesthetically?
How do we envision sexual justice
within and across activisms and intimacies
inside and beside pandemic life?
So we will start with Che
Gossett and go down the row.
Also, there's lots of
like snacks and coffee,
so make sure you get that
at the end of the event.
Okay, I'll turn it over to you.
Cool.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so much, Joe and to Rod
and to the amazing co
Brudner roundtable panelists.
It's such an honor to be here.
And especially someone who's
been reading your individual
and collective work for many years,
I appreciate this invitation
to think through this question
of sexual justice.
So I'm just gonna be reading
and thinking through sexual
justice through the aesthetic,
through art, through black trans art
in the afterlife of slavery,
and hopefully during the Q and A,
can talk through some
of the cardinal points
or orientation points
that you brought up, Joe,
that kinda anchor this the conversation.
So I want to open with a
quote by Hortense Spillers.
In order to name the
black woman in the sexual,
the investigator is obliged
to back all the way up
to that suspenseful chapter in
the unfolding of subjecthood
which begins for Africanity
in the West, not with a body,
which one sees well enough,
but with which that body was made to mean,
with what that body was made to mean
via the powerful grammars of capture.
Building on black feminist
and literature professor,
Hortense Spillers's
theoretical articulation
of grammars of capture,
my work considers how great
these grammars function
as the political vernacular
through which carceral regimes
are both rehearsed and renewed.
I examine aesthetic objects and
cinematic interventions made
by black radical queer and
trans performers and artists
and writers and how these
interventions perform
a deconstruction of what she
calls the grammars of capture
and the carceral
metaphysics of the subject
by marshaling fugitive forms of aesthetics
and untraditional archives.
So in this brief talk or segment,
I think through the work of my sibling,
the black trans artist, Tourmaline,
and how she engages in
what Saidiya Hartman terms,
critical fabulation
in resistance to the
aesthetic and racial regime
of the archive of slavery,
at the same time in
resistance to the normative
and neoliberal politics of what today
we call transvisibility in
our contemporary moment.
Black trans historical
figures are fugitive
to the terms of the official archive,
except in moments of criminalization
when they appear through
register of the police record
or the court transcript.
Which is where the 1836
case of Mary Jones enters
into the realm of historical
legibility and visibility.
I first encountered the
historical figure of Mary Jones
in Tavia Nyong'o who's here,
who does amazing work in his
text, "Amalgamation Waltz."
And like any proper archivist,
I immediately rushed to
order the court transcript.
Jones was arrested in 1836.
She was a sex worker in New York City.
She was brought into court,
sensationalized through like
a lithograph that circulated,
went viral for this
early age of print media.
And also was interrogated for
her gender in the courtroom
and it was this spectacle
and political theater.
And so in the courtroom, she's asked,
"Who taught you to dress this way?"
And she replies defiantly,
"I've always dressed this way
"amongst people of my own color."
And so that always is really
profound in terms of thinking
about black trans temporalities
and existence and resistance.
So in "Salacia", Tourmaline's
film about Mary Jones,
which is an aesthetic mediation
and critical fabulation of her biography,
Jones is played by actor Rowin Amone
who's pictured here.
Tourmaline's work moves
in the liminal space
between the historical
record of black trans life,
as well as the realm of the magical.
It is black, queer, and
trans speculation part
of an aesthetic legacy and genealogy
in tradition of Octavia Butler,
who Rod is gracing our
presence within his T-shirt,
Chip Delany and also the
myriad of such films,
insurgent aesthetics of such films
as "Born in Flames" that
guides the optics of "Salacia."
The short film takes
place in Seneca village,
a punitively free black enclave
that was eventually destroyed,
showing the rues of
black property ownership,
property in self or of objects,
and it was raised to erect
what is now Central Park,
and that happened in the 1850s.
"Salacia" dramatizes
the intramural tensions
that cut across and through
the black community.
A community rendered
always already under duress
by slave catchers in the North
as well as what Frank Wilkinson calls
the emergency of civil society itself.
A black abolitionist, Peter
Dermot runs both a free press
and a boarding house
and watches with this day out the window
as Jones engages in illicit sex work
and trade with white men outside.
The intramural then is
not without its fractures
and fissions.
Men monster posters surround the city,
which actually happened
in the historical record.
And these lithographs are
pasted walls and trees
signifying that Jones is wanted.
The entire community
is also subject always
to imminent capture.
Jones's situation there
is both the collective
and intermural one, but also
the particular predicament
of black trans fugitivity.
Dermot disapproves of
Jones immorality and vice,
but still provides her refuge.
In the version of the film installed
at the Brooklyn Museum,
which was this amazing kind
of 50th anniversary exhibition
commemorating Stonewall,
titled "Nobody Promised You Tomorrow"
which was a Marsha P. Johnson quote,
we see the glimpse of
a glimmer of an affair.
While Dermot judges Jones
for her cardinal sins of the flesh,
he is not protected by respectability.
The police storm his home
looking for Jones showing
that black life is never safe or protected
and that autonomy is always
equality of whiteness
as bodily and communal sovereignty.
They threatened to close down
his entire establishment.
Jones goes on the run.
Fugitive, she is cornered,
trapped, resists, bites,
but is overpowered and arrested.
She knows magic however.
And this is part of a kind of ode to
or kind of enactment of black cosmological
and African indigenous traditions.
So she uses magic to time
travel to the present,
which is also part of a
black speculative imaginary
of 19th century fiction
and slave narratives
like Freddie Douglass' narrative,
where he gets a magical
amulet from his friend, Sandy,
that he says is part of the,
kind of gave him power to
overthrow Master Covey.
So in this film, Jones
uses water as a transport
and moves through in
between time allowing her
to escape the confines of her jail cell.
And in doing so, she
violates the laws of physics
and moves queerly or what Tavia Nyong'o
might call in an angular fashion
across the entanglement of space time.
So in some ways the film is about
what Daphne Brooks calls escapology.
She manages to escape
one version of capture,
the pre-emancipation past
only to land in another,
which would be the anti-black
present of Central Park.
Tourmaline's film asked
us to consider the ways
in which anti-black and
anti-trans temporalities
are insufficient for black trans freedom
and how the world remains
a grammar of capture.
The film raises questions
about sexual justice and fugitivity,
and the condition of black trans existence
beyond the racialized
and anti-trans world.
And so I wanna end with some questions.
What might happen in the
realm of the aesthetic,
which is disallowed and foreclosed
in the realm of the political?
Where does the aesthetic
begin and the political end?
Black literary and aesthetic practices
have historically been a spear in an arena
where the political and its
representative functions,
racial liberalism slash democracy,
are left aside for
alternative imaginaries.
Or where the strict boundaries
between the two dissolve
in their interplay.
So thinking about Toni
Morrison's "Beloved"
to Sutton Griggs' fictional imagining
of a sovereign black state.
So in both fiction and nonfiction,
these instead become areas or genres
where political experimentation happens
and where justice to come is staged.
And in "Salacia," the
philosophical edifice
of justice emerges from a vantage point
of the runaway slave, the
radical ethics of the slave
that aims for what Moton
and Harney emphatically say,
charge or demand the
abolition of a society
that could even have prisons itself.
And so therefore,
abolition is an unfinished
and open invitation to
an emancipatory project
that's both interior and
exterior perennial as well.
And so I think, I guess just to close,
I feel curious about the political grammar
of sexual justice given that justice
is often part of a
grammar of legal capture
and incrementable justice and the law
are often collapsed into
each other and conflated.
But of course, from
Walter Benjamin to Derrida
to Martin Luther King
Jr., we learn all about,
there's a whole wealth of kind of study
that thinks about the incrementability
of justice and the law.
And so I wonder about the
grammar of sexual justice
and perhaps maybe if there might be ways
to imagine a new political grammar
beyond the idea of justice itself,
which kind of carries a baggage
that's all about like
reconciliation, restitution,
two sides that come into
kind of a cosmic balance.
And so I guess I have that
left as an open question
for us to all consider together.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Excuse me.
- Okay.
(indistinct whispering)
- Can you see?
- I can, I can.
I think I can, so this will
move it back and forth.
Okay, thank you.
Okay.
Can you hear me?
So I wanna thank Professor
Fischel for the invitation.
It's great to be here and
among such great scholars.
What is sexual justice?
So since I wrote my
book, "Intimate Justice"
and the "North American
Necropolitics and Gender"
that Professor Fischel's students read,
I've learned a great deal
from black feminists,
sovereign queer and trans abolitionists,
namely from Beth Richie, Dana Melion,
Nick Estes, and Melanie Yazzie.
Cathy Cohen, Eric Stanley,
Dean Spade, Mariame
Kaba, and Andrea Ritchie.
So I've learned about the role of police,
not only in enforcing gender normativity,
policing gender and gender expression,
but also in the disproportionate
interpersonal violence
that black women experience.
So my book and the article, I think,
focused on intimate interpersonal violence
and really on that, as
opposed to state violence
and these authors as well
as activist formations,
including Insight and
Kaba's Survived and Punished
have helped me to see
more clearly something
like intimate state by violence.
So that includes the role
of police and policing
as well as a broader
tough on crime approach
in perpetuating violence against women,
particularly black women
who violate gender norms
though black women violate gender norms
by their existence in some sense.
Now, but also not only in
perpetuating the violence,
but in escalating the
interpersonal violence,
gender-based violence
that they experience.
Now, my current research
looks at the politics
of black death and how black politics
from lynching to the
movement for black lives
has centered spectacular death.
This presents a problem for black women
who are less likely to be
killed in the spectacular ways
that CIS black men are.
Men are more likely to be
killed in public generally
by acquaintances and strangers,
and in the era inaugurated
by the Rodney King beating
more likely to have the violence and death
that they experience
filmed and circulated.
Women on the other hand are more likely
to be killed in private by intimates
and because of intimacy.
This is often even the
case when black women
are killed by police.
So Andrea Ritchie states
that police brutality
against black women takes
place inside the home,
and it is often unseen as a result.
So here, Breonna Taylor's death echoes
the deaths of many Black women whose names
are now called upon to say,
including Eleanor Bumpurs,
Aiyana Stanley-Jones,
Atatiana Jefferson, Kathryn Johnston,
Shirleen Alaos, and Pearlie Golden.
So much of the violence
takes place inside the home,
in welfare offices, patrol
cars, or even in precincts,
as women attempt to report
intimate partner violence.
A significant portion
of the violence happens
when black and other
marginalized women ask for help
in their intimate relationships.
So on the violence and death that occurs
at the intersection of the war on drugs
and the sphere of intimate relations
as was the case with Taylor.
So a warrant was issued
for Taylor's arrest
because of her association,
her intimacy with her former partner.
And she's now dead.
Here, no knock warrants
themselves continue
this country's brutal and
often deadly regulation
of the black intimate sphere.
Now, as the organization, and I say,
as the organization Survived and Punished,
co-founded by the
incomparable Mariame Kaba,
abolitionist, organizer,
this organization argues
effectively that jails and prisons
and not rape crisis centers,
and women's shelters
actually represent our
collective institutional response
to the problem of gender-based
violence against black
and other marginalized women.
So the SCLU estimates that almost 60%
of people women's prisons worldwide
are survivors of violence.
And at some prisons, there's
numbers as high as 94%.
Now, I wanna be clear
to mark the distinction
between sex and sexual violence here.
Though I also wanna be clear that women
are experiencing sexual violence
in this institutional context
because they are in intimate
relationships and have had sex.
I wanna mark the fact that
black women are being murdered,
killed, severely hurt, and punished
ultimately because they have had sex,
and this creates significant political
and organizational problems.
But my research looks
not only at this aspect,
but also at what I've come to
call black women's death work.
So here, women like Ida B.
Wells, Mamie Till Bradley,
that is Emmett Till's mom,
and Clementine Barfield
of Detroit's Save Our Sons and Daughters,
also known as SOSAD,
which is an organization
of the mothers of murdered
children founded in the 1980s
and connected to our current era
and its own politics of death.
As Trayvon Martin's
mother contacted SOSAD's
Philadelphia chapter,
they were among the first
to bring attention to
the death of her son.
So each of these women made
transformational contributions
to the black counter public sphere
and their entry into that public sphere
was authorized by a man's death.
Now, the subtitle for my
section on Madam Wells
is Wells and the Empirical Miracle.
And I talk about how she
constructs a black truth apparatus
from broken white parts.
And she's the first to
use a lynching photo
in anti-lynching work,
a strategy that we know will
be repeated for years to come,
but she also commissions
a portrait of herself
with her murdered friend,
Thomas Moss's family
and Lee Rayford says that this represents
her important expansion of
the lynching photo genre,
bringing the family left behind
into the frame of anti-lynching activism.
Now, I'm in the process
writing the section
on Barfield and SOSAD,
and I could literally go
on for hours about them,
but let me just say that the
organization was extraordinary.
So two weeks after one
of her sons was killed
and another gravely injured
in an active teen violence,
Barfield organized a meeting
for families affected
by violence against children and teens.
The resulting organization became,
according to youth violence expert
and former assistant dean
of Harvard School of Public
Health, Deborah Prothrow-Stith,
I quote, a model for
community based activism
for organizing for the
rest of the country.
SOSAD would go on to have an impact
on national conversations
regarding youth violence
and at its peak, receive requests
for organizing help from
Milwaukee, St. Louis, Atlanta,
Los Angeles, San Francisco,
Columbus, and Omaha,
chapters were started in Flint, Michigan,
Fresno, Birmingham,
Alabama, and St. Louis,
and I told you about the
Philadelphia chapter,
which was the largest and
perhaps most important.
Now they ran a grief support group
for the mothers of murdered children.
The support group would expand
to include a family support group,
a male grief support group,
a child counseling group,
a survivors of violence group.
They ran a 24-hour crisis highline
and provided mental health
services for children who hurt.
They organized a crisis intervention team
that went into schools, churches,
and door-to-door neighborhoods
after area death.
They had a speakers bureau,
a monthly newsletter with columns
by Barfield and James
Boggs, a weekly radio show.
They kickstarted the
Urban Gardening Movement
with their harvesting program,
and they even organized in prisons.
Now, members of the organization
held an explicitly theory
of what allowed violence to
proliferate in the community,
and that was the seating
of public state space.
So Barfield would say,
"Instead of hiding behind
barred doors and windows,
"we can and must march out
of our homes and our churches
"and begin walking the streets
in large and small groups,
"making clear to everyone, young and old,
"that we are reclaiming our communities,
"looking out for each other
"and saving our sons and daughters."
Earlier in the same
column, Barfield would say,
"Every time one of our sons
and daughters is killed,
"we must march, we must
hold candlelight vigils,
"we must create people's
memorials to show that we care.
"We must not allow Daniel Barr,
Gary Irwin and Otis Haley,
"or any of our lost loved ones
"to be turned into faceless statistics.
"On street corners like Joy and Evergreen,
"we must paint their
portraits to remind us
"that each one of them was someone's son,
"someone's brother, someone's friend."
"We have to physically
plan ourselves," she said,
and she would make
reference to trees a lot,
"at the scene of every
shooting or homicide
"in our neighborhood, we
must make hope visible.
"Our children need to
see with their own eyes
"in the midst of devastation
"that people are standing together
"and struggling for a better world,"
but this was not all, right?
So she says, "We have to organize
"to rebuild our communities.
"Everyone can do something,
"we could march against the
crack house on our block,
"we can develop treatment programs,
"we can transform vacant
lots into community gardens
"and children's parks where
kids can play together.
"We can work towards
creating small businesses
"to provide jobs.
"We can organize block
parties and festivals
"to celebrate the positive
achievements of youth."
Now justice then was not about punishment,
but the work of building a better world.
Justice for the women's dead children
was bringing about an end to death worlds
and creating life worlds in their place.
Communing, however, with
death world, dead children,
even as they built these life worlds.
So significantly, they had
a much more sophisticated understanding
of the causes of violence,
and at times an implicit,
but often explicit critique
of the war on drugs and
the carceral state approach
to violence.
Additionally, they embraced
a form of community accountability
that is endorsed by
contemporary abolitionists.
So Melinda Price who's written
on the organization says,
"Through their relationship
with their children,
"both dead and living,"
and here, Price is referring
to what she's calling
the afterlife of black motherhood,
where these organizations,
organized mothers of
murdered children continue
to parent their children by
creating nurturing communities
for kids amidst the
violence and destruction
of urban abandonment in the war on drugs,
that is life worlds in
the midst of death worlds,
but Price continues,
"They crafted public roles
to solve complex problems
"at its roots.
"In this sense, their analysis
was more complex and astute
"than the analysis that
informed any government program.
"They understood that solving
the problem of violence
"against and among black
children meant surrounding them
"with love, building healthy self-esteem,
"and finding meaningful work for teenagers
"on the cusp of adulthood."
So I'm thinking about the
relationship between Wells,
Till Bradley, and Barfield's
death work for racial justice
and the death work that must
be done for the women who die
because they have had sex today.
Now, someone pointed out the difference
in the public's acceptance
of grief in public
for the mothers of a murdered child
and their life world
creating grief in public,
and the difference between that, right,
and grief in public for
women who've had sex.
And I think this is an important point.
But as I've thought about it,
I realize that Price reminds us
that at the time of SOSAD's work,
the predominant understandings
of the black mother
was the welfare queen and the crack queen.
So these women had no easy road to hope.
And perhaps, the gap
between these two archetypes
is not as far apart as we might think.
In any case, just this week
I became struck by the
similarity of Barfield
and Kaba's theory of what justice demands.
So across three to four decades,
they seem to have come
to the same conclusion.
And you may or may not
be surprised to learn
that it aligns with the
conclusions of Iris Marion Young,
that justice requires participation,
participatory democracy,
that we cannot create something good
with which we are not
all involved in making.
So institutionally, the tough
on crime approach must end
for there to be sexual justice,
but we must all be involved in
the creating of institutions.
I can't say what I think
sexual justice will look like.
Like Barfield and Kaba, I believe
that we all have to say
that collectively together.
And I do believe that like
them, we can't have it
if we abdicate our
collective responsibility
for providing sexual safety for us all.
But I do think that it will involve
all of us creating life worlds of the kind
that Barfield's organization
attempted to do.
Thank you.
(crowd applauding)
- All right, I'm gonna stand up,
but I don't have any slides,
but I thought I'd stand.
Okay, so I'm talking about sexual justice
and I'm taking sexual
down to its its root, sex,
and by sex, I mean sex as an M or F or X,
not as sex as in having sex.
So that's my sex part.
The justice, I think, we'll
get to around the end.
But one other short note on language,
many people would use gender
to talk about the marks
on our driver's license
and the passports and so on.
But I use the word sex,
and let me explain why.
This is the thing, I can either see you
or I can see my paper, so
I think I'll see my paper
and you all blurry, oh, well.
- Or look at folks here.
- Okay, so a lot of my work is focused
on how state actors define the word sex
or decide who's M or who's F or who's X.
And I am not interested in
evaluating the correctness
of different claims to
deciding on who's M or F or X.
So what I do is I look at
what different definitions make possible.
So I don't know what sex is.
I don't know what the right thing is.
I'm just like, let's see what,
a definition that a government
agency puts forward,
that's back by the force of
law, what effects that has.
So I use gender though, I
still use the word gender,
but I refer to, by gender
I refer to like shared,
though often contested
norms, narratives, practices,
and conventions that are age,
bodies, identities, roles,
and expressions in
hierarchies of different
based on binary notions
of male and female,
masculine and feminine and so on.
So just a little introduction.
So in the last month,
Supreme Court nominee,
Ketanji Brown Jackson, was
castigate by a Republican Senator
for refusing to define the word woman
in her nomination hearings.
A week later, the Biden
administration announced
that individuals will have
the option of choosing X
as the gender marker on their passport.
I should say sex marker, sorry?
So it's quite a weird moment or act.
Though the right and the left
are like bitterly divided,
by the left, I mean the
good left, my kind of left,
not the old lefty boys who
don't like trans people,
whether the right and the
left are brutally divided
over the rights of transgender people,
activists on both sides
agree on one thing,
if their side can win
the battle of how society
as a whole defines a person's sex,
Americans will be forced
to either give up,
discriminate against trans people,
or be allowed to continue
discriminate against trans people.
So it's like, the way the
rhetoric kind of moves around,
it's as the faded republic
depends in no small measure
on the outcome of the
battle over sex definition.
But this notion of a
kind of mannequin battle
between the sexes, however,
rests on a dramatically
mistaken view of how state,
federal, and local
governments approach the issue
of deciding a person's sex.
Whether it's on a birth certificate,
a driver's license, a
marriage certificate,
whether it's in a prison,
a homeless shelter or school bathroom,
historically, government agencies
have been far less interested
in social conventions
about what sex is,
whether it's biological
assignment at birth,
gender identity as an adult and so on.
They're less interested
in the perfect definition
in some abstract platonic way
than what sex does for
that agency's mission.
So officials in prison, for example,
define sex differently than do officials
in the department of motor vehicles.
Even when those officials
work in the same jurisdiction
of a single city or a state.
So sex classifications radically depend
in ways that few journalists
and scholars and politicians recognize,
except we do 'cause we're in this world,
sex classifications depend
on what a government agency
is trying to do.
So I wanna kind of illustrate this
by telling a story of New York City.
And I'm the kid at the
Thanksgiving dinner table
who like started to tell a story,
and by the time I got to the
end, no was paying attention.
So in my '50s, I'm still like,
maybe I can tell a story,
but here I have a microphone,
and you probably won't interrupt me,
but I'm gonna try to tell a story
and not mess up any punchlines.
So in the 1960s, trans
people were going to the city
and saying, "Hey, will you
change our birth certificates?"
And the city was like, "Wow,
I don't know, that's weird."
So they did it a few
times, and after a while,
they were like, "I'm not
sure this is a good idea."
So they asked a bunch of doctors,
should we change their birth certificates?
The doctors met or three
times, and they were like, "No.
"Because if you let them change
their birth certificates,
"they might commit a
fraud upon the public,
"by like marrying some
unsuspecting person,"
their image was of a trans woman marrying
an unsuspecting cisgender man
who would accidentally get
married to a trans woman.
So they wouldn't change it.
Then in the 1970s, I think it was the SOU
or the New York Civil Liberties Union,
tried to get the city
to change its policy.
And the city did.
It said, "Okay, this is a weird issue.
"You know what we're gonna do?
"We're gonna give you
new birth certificates,
"but we're gonna take the
box that indicates sex off."
There's no box whatsoever.
So everybody else has
a box that says M or F,
and trans people's birth certificates,
people who were born in
the city, there's no box,
which isn't great for people
who had to present their
birth certificates,
'cause people who look at
birth certificates all day
would say, well, this is a trans person,
'cause there's no box here,
but anyways, it was something.
But by the 2000s, New York City,
thinking of itself as
very progressive thought,
okay, we're a little behind.
In the 70s, this might
have been a cool policy,
but now of this is behind.
So they convened a committee,
and this is where I come
into it as like an expert,
but probably more of
an advocate, actually.
They convened a committee to decide like,
okay, what should the right policy be
for letting people change their sex marker
in their birth certificate.
So they had trans healthcare advocates,
transgender rights advocates.
They had surgeons, they had psychiatrists,
and of the people who were
not on the city's payroll,
so some of the people were city officials,
but the people who weren't
on the city's payroll,
everybody worked hard to
convince policy makers
to drop the requirement
for any kind of surgical
or medical intervention.
The only people who
didn't work for the city
who wanted to keep a surgical
requirement were surgeons.
They thought that was a good metric
for changing people's sex.
The good thing is they made
so much money in private practice,
coming to a meeting cost them
a lot of money was presumed,
so they did like came to one meeting,
so that was actually quite helpful.
But we kind of made the usual argument,
transition is an individualized process
and gender identity, not genitals,
should determine sex classification.
And initially, the Board of Health,
which is the group we were working with,
agreed to adopt this recommendation.
But then they shopped it
around to other city agencies,
and the other city agencies said,
"No, this is a terrible
policy, we don't agree."
And our proposal was
shelved for some years.
So we decided, the advocates
on the committee decided
that this is just plain transphobic.
This is like not okay.
This is just mean.
We would talk about the
harms that people face
when there is a mismatch
between the M or the F
on a person's identity papers
and their gender identity.
There's a great quote,
one woman who testified
to the city officials said, she says,
"I don't suffer from gender dysphoria.
"I suffer from bureaucratic dysphoria."
She kind of talks about the
problem is the state's problem.
So that's like very powerful,
and I was there when
that statement was made.
But one thing that my
thinking has shifted on this
is that focusing on the
harm to transgender people
that these decisions make,
actually in some sense,
makes it hard to see
what the city was doing
and what their reasoning was.
It just seemed transphobic.
But as a few years later,
I was doing some research,
I came across some material
that provided a different perspective.
So back in the '60s when the New York City
was trying to figure out what to do,
they wrote some official in Washington.
They said, well, what do you do,
you people at the Bureau of Statistics
or somebody at the Department of Health,
Education, and Welfare,
and the federal government
people wrote back and said,
"We thought about this and
I canvased a bunch of people
"from other departments
and we can provide you
"with no guidance on the question."
He said, "Since various agencies carry out
"differing responsibilities,
"the problems which confront them vary.
"The more we delved into the problem,
"the more ramifications that corrupt up."
So this for me was like looking
at sex classification stuff,
it's so fascinating, 'cause
they're based talking about
how sex is an instrument
of governmentality,
though that's another
language they were using,
and not talking about sex is
in some kind of abstract thing.
So officials at some agencies
like the Social Security Administration
were worried about identity management
and social security benefits.
They were worried, the
Selective Service people
were worried, all the
different agencies were like,
"Oh, I'm not sure about this."
So in other words, there
could be no unified policy
on the matter of sex reclassification
because each agency
would have to investigate
the effects of sex
reclassification policies
on its own work.
And then back to the
2005 policy that failed,
a transgender rights group sued the city.
They said, "This is not
okay, this is mean."
They said that the requiring
individuals to have surgery
before their birth
certificate could be changed
was arbitrary, capricious, discriminatory,
and otherwise unlawful, and
the law, which is boring,
but in the law, it's like it's bad
to be arbitrary and capricious,
they're supposed to be a
good reason for things.
So the advocates were drawing
on medical authorities
to argue that sex markers
and identity documents
should be consistent with the
individual's gender identity,
drawing on all this like social
science and medical science.
So the city's policy according
to advocates was irrational.
And the response of the city's lawyers
kind of goes back to the
response of that federal official
in the 1960s.
They argued that the existence
of different approaches
to sex classification
does not render an
agency's rule irrational.
For the city, the rationality
of each agency's approach
to sex classification depended
on what the agency did
on its remit, not on
what sex is in itself.
So the debate on sex was taking place
in two different registers.
So the advocates including myself,
we were thinking about experts and truth,
and how to really think about what sex is.
And the bureaucrats were
thinking about governing,
about like what a sex
classification would do to a prison
or homeless shelter or a different agency.
So for the city,
how sex was defined could
be changed by agency
depending on the need.
So I like to tell this story
because it shows how advocates,
including myself, working on this issue
went into the process,
thinking the point was degree
on some right definition of sex,
but it turned out that
the city bureaucrats
and lawyers were the real facadeans,
understanding that sex
was not a thing in itself,
but something instrumentalized differently
by different agencies.
So, so much scholarship and
advocacy has been taken up
with arguing that it's unjust
to use traditional ideas about gender
to require transgender
people to have surgery
before changing their sex classification
or to prevent any changes at all.
A lot of like, that is just wrong,
and I agree with that, it is wrong.
But from these precincts, we
also hear that sex and gender
are so complicated that
the only workable solution
is to mix base sex classification
on gender identity.
I don't disagree with that either,
but the other assumption that bad policies
are the result of transphobia
and that good policies are
not doesn't help us understand
how every one of them fixes us in place,
implicates us in a relation to state power
that might allow some reforms
of sex classification,
but draws our attention
away from the other half
of the equation, state power.
So we spend a lot of
time denaturalizing sex,
but like we're not so good
at denaturalizing the state.
You know what I mean?
No one reads marks anymore.
I mean, maybe maybe it's
getting turned in reasonably,
but so the proposition,
and I was doing this paper this morning,
I was like, boy, like every paper
a political theorist ever presents.
it's really just another version
of Marx's "On the Jewish Question".
So I apologize for that,
I guess that's the tradition I'm in,
but the proposition
that sex is manufactured
in and through regulations,
formal and informal policies,
judicial decisions, and legislative
enactments does not mean
that we should see the
state as fixed in place,
still and hard as a monument.
That sex is an output doesn't mean
that we should black box the state,
like turn into a thing that we don't look
into its inner doings.
So before I conclude, one last word
about the New York City situation,
New York City now has a great policy.
You can change it to F to M to X,
you don't need a doctor's letter,
you don't need any medical intervention.
That's all really, it's
the perfect policy.
But it's not like the city finally agreed
that sex really should be gender identity.
It was because the new
logic of identity politics
meant that the de Blasio administration
could give this
constituency what it wanted.
He said, "I can give you,"
in the press release,
"We're getting transgender
people what they want."
But everybody else born the
city still gets an M or an F
on their birth certificate.
So we're still kind of trapped
in this arithmetic of identity politics
of demands made and demands met.
So to conclude, to return
to the powerless moment
in which we find ourselves,
where we have passage of
legislation targeting trans youth
and those who care for them,
bills excluding trans girls from sports,
don't say gay bills, the organized attack
on what's taken to be gender ideology,
I mean that's more
outside the United States,
but as scary as this moment is,
I see two positive or exciting,
hopefully, they're exciting possibilities.
First, sex classification has
always been instrumentalized
for the purposes of governance,
we're already there.
But what was previously
a relatively secretive
internal decision of government
bureaucrats concerned
with the efficiency and
effectiveness of their agencies
in particular state projects
has very recently become a
boisterous public debate.
For the first time, the
decision about gender identity
has the potential to be democratic,
not only deliberated by the people,
but with the interests or concerns
of the people most
affected by those policies,
trans people taken into account.
Second, as we put the needs
of transgender people front
and center in deliberations
about sex classification,
it's also an opportunity
to shine the spotlight
on the other side
of this mutually
constitutive relationship,
the governing opposite apparatuses
that determine what a
livable life looks like.
So we can get sex classification right.
We can fight in the democratic
public sphere for that.
That's good.
But it's also important
to kind of point out
like we can get everybody's,
every jurisdiction's,
every agency's sex
classification policy right,
but the changes that'd improve the lives
of the most trans people are
not those changes, right?
Those changes would be
having public health,
a national healthcare
plan, prison abolition,
and like radically reducing,
if not eliminating income inequality.
Those are the things that would
change most people's lives.
So as we contest the classifications,
the exclusions from
public life, the attacks,
the CPS investigations,
this is also a moment to turn
the spotlight, not on sex,
but back to the state and think about
the very architecture of justice
that distributes inequality.
So thank you.
(audience applauding)
- So I wanna start by thanking
Joe and Gender Studies
for inviting me to sit on this panel
alongside three people whose work
is tremendously influential,
both in my prior book
and particularly in some
of what I'm working on now.
So I'm the one who's gonna talk about sex,
because this is an LGBT studies thing,
and it's time, it's time.
We're gonna talk about,
I'm gonna put the sex in sexual justice.
So I'm a micro-sociologist,
which means that I study
themes of intimacy recognition
from a kind of perspective
that foregrounds face to face interaction
and thinking through the ways
in which we live social structures
in our most intimate lives and moments.
And so I'm gonna be
talking a little bit today
about what sexual justice
demands of us interpersonally.
So for the last several years
up until COVID made it impossible,
I was conducting ethnographic research
in several different BDSM communities.
Now I'm guessing that that if you're
at an LGBT studies talk,
this is not the first time
you've heard the term BDSM,
but when I talk about it,
really what I'm focusing on
is sets of erotic practices
and emotional practices
that rely on a hierarchical
organization of power
between people.
And as I began to do the writing
of what will be this ethnographic book,
I realized that a lot
of what I was learning
was about the erotic life
of social difference.
How differences between
people related to gender,
sexuality, race, class,
nationality, religion,
and age become activated, even
electrified by the erotic,
brought into focus,
crystallized in the moment.
Now, the ways sexuality makes
gender turn technicolor,
or makes racial difference animated,
how social roles anchored in power
like teacher-student, for example,
which we were talking
about at lunch today,
gather intense affect.
And usually, we think of these things
in negative terms, right?
As structures of power underlying
bodily forms of violence
like rape and psychic forms of
violence like sexual racism.
And these are deeply
important social pathologies.
But on some level, I think
it lets nonviolent sex
off the hook by way of
locating unjust sexuality
only in moments of
non-consensual violence, right?
Whether it's structural or interpersonal.
And so I wanna focus on two
epistemological responses
to sort of transgressive sexuality
that I think are complicit
in this exceptionalizing of violence
in non-consensual forms of sexuality.
So the first is a framework
common in queer social
and psychoanalytic theory
that positions redemptive
sexuality as antisocial,
anti-rational and ego shattering
to use Leo Bersani's formulation,
or the more popular often
attributed to feminist notion
that sex is either presumptively
egalitarian and thus good,
or it sits in relation to trauma,
as either it's self traumatic,
the cause of trauma,
or a means of repairing it.
And I wanna offer two
observations from my work,
both of which are preliminary.
See, here's the thing
about doing empirical work.
If you really, like real people keep you
kind of intellectually
honest in a certain way.
And so I think that they're often
a good place to start, right?
Like when we're thinking about
how things work in the world.
So I wanna say two things today.
First, I wanna argue for something
that I'm coming to call
articulate intimacy,
which one might even consider
a hyper rational orientation
towards desire and pleasure.
And second, I'm gonna suggest
that we think differently
than queer theorists often
do about the connection
between pleasure and
negative affect, right?
That we think about ways to
imagine states beyond pleasure
that facilitate eroticized
forms of intimacy
that are deeply grounded
in social location.
So BDSM is what sociologists call
an extreme case of intimate relation,
in the sense that we view it
as deviant or exceptional,
in the sense that we have
a sense that this is not
what most people do.
But BDSM is also, as Ariana Cruz writes,
an aperture through which to
view some of the architecture
of the sexual order more generally.
So in my travels through BDSM subcultures,
I met people who engaged in
various forms of psychological
and erotic play that traffic
in social difference,
race play, rape play, Nazi
play, these are some examples.
And in my conversations
with these practitioners,
women and people of color
had extremely articulate
relationships to their play,
particularly those who occupy
the minoritarian positions
in erotic encounters with others.
Men and white people of
all genders struggled more
with articulating their investments
or individual level experiences
with reproducing most
particularly racialized domination
in their play.
And I began thinking
about the inarticulateness
of whiteness as perhaps
one of the biggest barriers
to sexual justice on the dyadic level.
And this is different from
what we hear about on NPR
when they're talking about
white fragility, right?
Which is a state of kind of
collapse into defensiveness
or anger at the challenge of
racial accountability, right?
This is a failure of cultural
language for attempting,
not merely accountability,
but an accounting for
the racialized nature
of all of our desires.
And this wasn't only the
case for my subjects.
This is true of dominant
queer theory as well.
I'm thinking of the work of
Tim Dean, David Halperin,
Leo Bersani and others,
mostly coming from white
gay male perspectives,
and some newer work in
psychoanalysis that foregrounds
the dissolution of the
self in the act of sex,
as kind of like the redemptive potential
of transgressive sexuality.
It's a kind of, and there's
a whole train of thought
in sociology as well that has
a kind of fantastical notion
of the sexual and sexual communities
as spaces that are acutely amenable
to transcending social difference, right?
On the other hand, black
feminist writing by Ariana Cruz,
Amber Musser, Jennifer
Nash, and others describes
a form of black and brown Jewish songs
that comes from a highly
racialized affect,
from attending to the
pleasures that are possible
by taking seriously the legacies of trauma
and rapture that define
the current racial moment.
Even by using negative
affect, not to aface the self,
but to confront it more
deeply and honestly,
than the sexual terrain
of egalitarianism allows.
And I say this not as a judgment
of my white subjects as individuals,
many of whom were engaged
in earnest efforts
toward accountability
in their intimate lives,
and indeed BDSM in its ideal form,
at least in the communities that I studied
is itself a form of articulate
intimacy by which I mean,
it is a form of relationship to others
that has a meta narrative about itself.
That accounts for specific
articulations of power
that exist within a
structure of accountability
that ensures not merely consent,
but specific forms of self-reflection.
The problem is that there were
few linguistic conventions
for people to draw on for
formulating racialized desires
outside of tropes of colorblindness,
objectification, or exclusion.
So some use the sexual
to find new grammars,
some means of counter that
coalesce outside of language,
ways of eroticizing in the body,
what can be so difficult
to narrate interpersonally.
So I really struggled with
deciding what anecdote
from my field work to share
with you in the brief moments
that I have for this provocation.
And so I scrolled through my
Rolodex of favorite perverts,
the upper east side,
it's really, it's getting
bigger every minute,
the upper east side
heterosexual Jewish couple
who enjoyed Nazi play on Shabbat,
the black-white lesbian
couple married for 20 years
who engaged in practices
of objectification
and the iconography of slavery.
The norm core couple who
maintained a 1950s household.
The American and Eastern European couple
who did mail order bride play,
or the time I was invited to participate
in an interrogation scene
by a well known black female dominant.
All would've led me to kind
of the same set of conclusions
that even in a context of
acute attunement to power,
social differences produce
what Rachel Gorman calls
a quagmire of affect, a
hazardous terrain of inarticulate
or invisible whiteness
that over-determines
what we know how to think,
what we know how we know to feel
and what we are able to say.
People of color who I interviewed
explicitly understood,
and women as well, either
gendered or racialized play
as either reformatting
objectification into recognition,
reversing the terms of subjectification
by either consenting to it
and thus not fully being an object,
but in fact, being a subject of it,
repeating it to gain mastery
or spinning the iconography
to subjectify either
maleness or whiteness.
They tied it to emotional
states like fear,
aggression, grief, shame, humiliation,
but always in contexts
with a very specificity
of their identities, and indeed,
BDSM identities themselves
often merge sexual
practices with orientations
to an individual's
particular constellation
of gender, racial, and
sexual identification.
So sociologists have written
a lot about how the sort
of contemporary moment
is a moment of specialized
erotics subcultures, right?
And these erotic subcultures often trade
not merely in what we want
to do with one another
or to one another,
but in the very particularity
of our identities,
and I mean that in a
deeply intersectional way.
White subjects understood
or really offloaded
their racialized investments
onto their partners.
I think of one white man who did race play
with his black partner,
"I am here to help her with
her process of reckoning,"
he said, "with what was done
by my forefathers to hers."
Right?
So I'm wondering if I have
time to tell one quick story.
I don't really, but I mean,
there's so many stories
that I could tell in which,
that reproduce this including ways
in which I was recruited by subjects
to take place in racialized scenes
that forced me to kind of
confront my own inarticulateness
about what it would
mean for me to do that.
And I say this not to collapse
into like an erotophobic discussion
about why we should or shouldn't
touch research subjects.
I have a whole paper on
that if you're interested.
And I have a whole, yes, I
have a whole paper on that,
but really like struggling
with the provocation made
by Tiffany King and many others,
for those of us working on
issues of social difference
from the position of whiteness
to really examine our
investments in racialization
or in avoiding its capture.
And I was thinking when
Che was talking earlier
about political experiments
beyond restitution,
that the interpersonal
domain in a context of trust,
in a context of mutuality
is a place where many people
are doing some of these experiments
in more just means of
attachment to one another.
And I think that I kind of
wanna argue for an agenda
that foregrounds what issues
of justice require of us
in our most intimate
encounters with others, right?
And to confront how we're going
to confront these affective
and linguistic failures that so many of us
were enculturated into.
But like most things that
are worth deep consideration,
this is not a new idea.
In fact, Robert Reed far
articulated this in 1998
when he wrote quote, and
I'm gonna end on this idea,
what is difficult to accept is
the idea that the sexual act,
at least as it is performed by queers,
it's not necessarily a good
expansive or liberatory thing.
A place in which individuals
exist for a moment
outside of themselves such
that new possibilities
are at once imagined and articulated.
Indeed I'm suggesting that this notion
is itself predicated upon the articulation
of a set of false boundaries.
We do not escape race
and racism when we f,
on the contrary, this fantasy
of escape is precisely
that which marks the sexual
act as deeply implicated
in the ideological processes,
by which difference is
constructed and maintained.
The task that awaits all of us then
is to speak desire plainly,
to pay attention to what we think when f,
more, it is the particular
task of white men
to give up the comforts of naivete
of banal gestures to racial inclusion.
Indeed, the work before us is precisely
to put our own bodies on the line.
We must refuse to allow
production of a queer theory,
so reified that it does
nothing to challenge
the way we interact, the way
we think, and the way we f.
We must not only think as we f,
but also pay close attention
to all the implications,
good and bad, of those
sometimes startling thoughts.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- So, oh, it is on, thank you all so much.
That was terrific.
I think we could just
move to your questions.
I don't think there's a mic there,
so maybe I'll run around
on with the mic, does that?
Yeah, okay.
But I think I'll turn it to you all
if there's that awkward
silence, I'll go first,
but is that a question?
Yeah, amazing, here.
- Yeah, thank you all so much
coming to speak with us today,
and thank you so much,
Joe, for organizing this.
I have question regarding refactoring
I always wanted to address it.
I'm interested in kind of other ways
in which, okay, totally.
Thank you.
I know you were talking
about kind of how to disrupt
the violence that occurs within the home
by like bringing grief into public space.
I'm interested if you or if anyone else
has other like thoughts on how to, yeah,
on how to disrupt like just
the interpersonal violence
that occurs within the home
and like what are ways to
bring like women who have sex
or like women who are
murdered because they have sex
into public space and like
what are the ideas you have
about that or thoughts.
- Do you want me to answer.
- Yeah, go for it.
- I don't know why I did that.
No, so this is something
that I'm really still thinking about.
This is, I'm what, three fifths of the way
through the book now.
So,
I'm thinking about
community accountability
and about what our own,
what our collective responsibility
towards interrupting violence.
I think Joe posed the
question about aesthetics.
I think that has an important role,
and my students have talked
in really convincing ways
about what the role of art is
in interrupting rape culture.
And students are most comfortable
thinking that education
is the way in which we have to do,
in which we access
and put into practice our
collective responsibilities,
but it is something that
I'm still thinking through,
and I actually would
welcome if other panelists
have something to say about it,
but I am early in thinking
about what this means.
I do, yeah, I'll just say that,
that I know that it's about
a line between publicity
and privacy, right?
So I mean, playing on
the public private divide
and specifically in intersectional
public private divide
where black women have
never belonged in private
in the same way that black men
kind of don't belong in public
space and their decision
to bring the grief into the public
when they didn't have
any real private, right?
Is an important one.
And trying to figure out the ways in which
to make these forms of
violence more visible
is the thing that brought
me to this project, right?
And so the fact that Barfield
is thinking constantly
about memorialization, about
statues, about artwork,
about making people into
more than statistics
into making that visible,
I think has something very,
like is an important part of this,
but it's about, I could
go off on a whole tangent
about how Les Moonves was at CBSs
and canceled "Designing
Women" and this like,
and then put a generation of
murdered women on TV, right?
And put that into our visual culture
and what it means that Tarana
Burke has a movie deal,
and how I think that that is
important for thinking about
how we interrupt those kinds of things.
So that's my, not quite there yet,
but the things that are moving
around in my head about it.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- I guess this is on.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I just wanted to,
I appreciate the question so much
and your presentation
so much, and I really,
it made me think a lot
about visual justice,
especially like the Ida B. Wells image
where she inserts herself in the picture
and then brings everybody
who's not in the picture into the fold
and that was so moving.
And I also, I think the question
in your presentation makes me think
about black trans woman being killed
both in private and in public
and in spectacular ways,
but despite the kind of spectacle,
horrifying spectacle of that violence,
there's not the political
mobilization as a response to it.
And so it just made me think about that
until really recently, like,
I think it was last summer,
I went to a black trans
pride march in Brooklyn,
outside of the Brooklyn Museum.
And there were like 10 to 15,000 people.
And that was unprecedented,
which felt like such a moving event,
but like how to sustain that momentum
in between the marches,
it's still like an ongoing,
like how to do that,
like beyond visibility, basically.
- Yeah.
- [Joe] Should I hold up?
- Yeah, I mean, I wrote this down
because I think that there's
so much to think about
in captive genders
where they talk about the
phenomenon of overkill,
but no one writes about it, right?
So we know that we only
find out about black women
being killed when they're
killed in the same news cycle
or by the same departments
that kill black men, right?
And so it follows that it
would be worse in a situation
where there's a suppression of information
and are not gonna talk about
it for black trans women
that we just, we won't know,
so we don't talk about it, right?
But the moving in the
public private divide
is really, it's tremendous.
But I do think that, as with Stonewall,
as with Save Our Sons
and Daughters, right?
As with Antifa, right,
never let a Nazi hold the street, right?
Being in the public,
and decision to occupy a public space
is a part of what this is, right?
And being there, being out
is a part of the solution.
And so even if it can't ever be 10,000
or there are only gonna be sporadic times
when it's gonna be that many,
like it is thinking about the
other ways to keep us there
is the thing that we're
fighting for, right?
- [Joe] Yeah. Go for it.
- Thanks, Jeff.
Hi, I'm Olivia, thanks
so much for your talk.
So listening to all of you
speak has me thinking about,
and this question has me thinking
about M. Jacqui Alexander's
idea of the palimpsest, right?
Which would have us think that
colonial forms of violence
have an arrangement of
like here and there,
and then and now, never
the twain shall meet.
And it seems like of you are
kind of invoking the importance
of at least some kind of
palimpsestic way of thinking
of we're thinking about here
and now, and then and there,
because I teach many of your works,
I'm wondering if you guys can talk about
the kind of pedagogical implications
of this palimpsestic way of thinking
or however you choose to interpret the way
that you are all thinking
about historical contingencies
here and there, then and now
for actually kind of bringing about
the various forms of sexual
justice you're invested in.
So I guess a short version of the question
is how does thinking about
the sort of deep histories
in all of your work,
how does that play a key role
in sort of thinking about
and manifesting an idea of sexual justice?
- You got, I'm gonna take
the liberty of a follow up,
which is, there's a strain,
like I said, "Eve" Cedrician strain
of the emphasis on the reparative
and not to get caught
in the paranoid, right?
And the kinds of ways that
the paranoid can be circular.
And so I want you to answer that question.
I mean, but to think, how can
you think the palimpsestic
along with,
how do you think the palimpsestic
and also the reparative at the same time,
I'll leave it there, right?
Or is the palimpsestic,
is it always kind of a paranoid turn?
Does it have to be, do
you see where I'm going?
Okay, go with Olivia first, yeah.
- Well, I mean, is the word palimpsest,
I'm so bad at English, but anyways.
- Oh yeah, it's just a phenomenal era,
it's something--
- You write over and over.
- Right, right.
- Yeah.
I think between the mask
and my like fear of my
terrible vocabulary,
I was like, is that the word?
I think for me, in terms of pedagogically,
like I teach at Brooklyn college
and like the last few semesters,
I've been almost the only
white person in the room.
So I feel like my role in this situation
can be in classes of like
intro to political theory.
I can try to historicize
sexual injustices,
a lot of those folks, and
maybe they need details,
but they don't need my help
historicizing questions
of like structural inequality
or histories of racism.
So it can be like a, in terms
of the mutual conversation
between professor and students,
and are at different
locations of privilege,
it could be like really generative.
But I feel like I learn
more from being in a room
with people who are living
in this never ending colonial moment
in terms of that informing my own work
on what we're calling
today sexual justice.
- Yeah, I mean, I resonate with that idea
in the sense that part of the intervention
that I think I was trying
to make is that the idea
that the current moment isn't always
an overwriting of a past is
really only a perspective one
can hold from a position of
incredible privilege, right?
And so there's a way in
which I think students come
into classrooms with an idea of equality
that is based in identity for people
who have more of a tangential
relationship to privilege,
and based more in a sense
of sameness for people
who have a tremendous degree of privilege,
whether that's economic
privilege, gender privilege,
racial privilege, whatever you wanna say.
And so I think that,
I mean, pedagogy has to meet people
where they enter a classroom
and move them one step beyond
where they came in, right?
Like that's what I consider
to be a successful a class, right?
Is that I've taken
somebody one step beyond
their starting point,
and people I'm from very
different starting points, right?
And so I think on some level,
what we have to explain and
to whom as Paisley pointed out
is really location dependent.
- So I've participated in a
seminar on the uses of the past.
And part of what came out
of that for my thinking was,
and it's in the book talking
about the power that lynching
has on contemporary US black politics,
and about the ways in
which lynching becomes away
that we talk about things
and the significance of
that for black women.
So very few black women
relatively were lynched,
about 5% according to your crystal fester.
And many of them were lynched
in place of a husband,
father, a brother that they couldn't find.
And so this means a lot
and this is significant.
And I think beyond that,
to talk about palimpsest,
it's the work that Du
Bois as the best among
but many others did
to connect lynching
and crucifixion, right?
So Du Bois has five, six lynching tales
where he brings a black Jesus to life
in the Jim Crow South.
He only speaks the words of
the biblical Jesus Christ,
this indicts everything that
goes on and he dies for it.
And I think that the martyr themes, right,
the resurrective work,
the things that are going
on are a powerful story.
And I've said, like a former
person here, Roger Smith,
who's not here anymore,
it's important in the
story of black people-hood,
and part of what black
women are gonna have to do
is tell a new story, right?
'Cause this is a rewriting
over and over again.
What do we do that black men
took the climax of the Bible,
but luckily we have Saidiya
Hartman and Toni Morrison
and others from whom
that we can think about
how to deal with these kinds of deaths
and ungrieved deaths.
But that's gonna be the way
that to write a new story,
to stop writing over the past
and think about how to put
one at least on equal footing
for thinking about the
origins of our politics.
- Thank you so much for that question,
and I felt really like transformed,
I guess I would say by reading
"Pedagogies of Crossing",
and so I always feel like
Jacqui Alexander's work
is like a condition of
possibility for my own thinking
and I feel very indebted to her labors,
critical labors, conceptual labors.
And I guess your question makes me think
about how to have an
abolitionist pedagogy,
both inside the university classroom
and what that might mean as
a worker in the university
and also inside the space of the prison.
And like what does an
abolitionist pedagogy look like
when you're teaching inside and outside?
And it also, I showed some of,
well, an image from
Tourmaline's film "Salacia",
and she really like folds
time and folds space.
And I think part of what that
does is like show the ruse
of racial liberal progress
narratives that would tell us
that for example cross-dressing
is decriminalized,
when it's not in prisons, right?
So I think that like showing
the foil of this teleological
kind of racial liberal time zone
is like part of what palimpsest,
now I'm like mispronounce it.
- Palimpsest.
- Part of what that project does,
and I think that that is crucial
to part of the demystification work
that an abolitionist pedagogy can offer,
can and does offer.
So thanks.
- Thank you.
- [Joe] I think maybe one more question.
I feel like it's close to seven.
Okay, great.
- [Gabby] Yeah, hi there, oh, that's loud.
I'm Gabby, Thank you so much
for coming to speak with us.
As you were all talking,
I was thinking a lot
about sexual injustice
beyond questions of consent,
like the unjust formation
of one's sexual proclivities
and preferences, sexual racism, et cetera.
And I am curious to hear from any of you
how we should approach talking
about how desire has a politics
and talking about ways to individually
and collectively reckon with that politics
without sliding into what sort
of sex positivity advocates
would call like prudish or
authoritarian sexual moralizing.
- I think that's on you.
- But you're gonna start.
You don't wanna take that one on?
I mean, look,
there are a lot of sociologists right now
that have been working
on sexual racism, right?
And I think that there are
these sort of two formulations.
One is that the intimate
realm is a place where,
it functions as a marketplace, right?
So that's often how sociologists
think about it, right?
That there is something
called a sexual field
in a Bourdieusian sense
in which different people,
because of what they look
like and their social position
have different amounts of erotic capital.
And this functions in
very predictable ways
to disadvantage women, people of color,
people who don't fit sort
of hegemonic standards
of beauty and so forth.
And that that is the
root from which we need
to begin to politicize desire.
Like what does it mean to,
I mean, it's sort of like,
there's like a website called
Douchebags of Grindr, right?
For example, where it's just like,
basically like all the
men's profiles who are like
no fats, no fems, no
blacks, like those people,
and as if they are an
individual level problem, right?
Whereas the actual problem
of desire is so much deeper
than bad behavior done
publicly by one person, right?
We are all complicit
in structures of desire
that disadvantage,
it's kind of like
when my mother wants to
give my daughter lessons
about sexuality, which I really
never want her to do ever,
and she's just like, "Date the nice boy."
But the truth is she means
like the nice handsome boy
who's gonna be a doctor, right?
Like that's what she means.
My daughter has come out as straight,
we're processing it in
therapy, I'm hoping.
I'm hoping she'll get
over it at some point but,
'cause heterosexuality these days seems,
as Jane Ward says, fairly tragic.
But another panel, but I do
think that the first step
in having a different
conception of desire,
and I hate this masculinist
economic framework
for understanding desire,
because I think that it's like everybody,
some people have got a thicker wallet
of desirability than others,
and I just think that
desire is so much more
of a, God, multivalent phenomenon.
But I do think that we are all complicit
in reproducing structures
of desire and desirability,
both in our presentations of self,
in the ways in which we value
or devalue other people,
even in terms of like, I
hope he's a doctor, right?
Like that is also a structure of desire.
And it's one that doesn't
really account for,
it's a cruel optimism, as
Lauren Berlant would say, right?
That you imagine who the
perfect partner is gonna be,
and oftentimes that
perfect partner is someone
then you enter into
like a completely miserable
marriage with, right?
And so really thinking
about what are the things
that make people desirable,
both erotically, right?
And maybe it's something
like they know what they're
doing in bed, right?
That would be nice, I mean,
I'd like to see the app
that kind of tries to get
at that algorithmically.
If you know of it, my
email's available online.
I mean, I think that part
of it is understanding
our own investments in
particular forms of partnership,
particular forms of erotic engagement
as being part and parcel
of an overall kind of,
like a structure of affect, right?
- [Joe] Question from you guys?
- We're good, okay?
- Okay, I think, I think we're set.
One last round of applause for our panel.
(audience applauds)